Are you sick of being cooped up at home, maybe trying to telework while the kids are screaming in another room? Are you tired of having to get swaddled in a mask and gloves to go out to the store, then anxious because people aren't maintaining the six-foot distance rule? Getting through the COVID-19 pandemic makes demands on our psyches. Resilience is one personality trait that will help us keep going with no end in sight. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Anne Maston, a professor in the Institute of Child Development at the University of Minnesota.
你是否厌倦了被关在家里，可能还要在孩子于另一个房间尖叫时尝试远程办公？你是否厌倦了出门去商店时必须把自己裹在口罩和手套里，然后因为人们没有保持六英尺的社交距离而感到焦虑？度过新冠疫情对我们的心理提出了要求。韧性是一种能帮助我们在看不到尽头的情况下坚持下去的人格特质。欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是明尼苏达大学儿童发展研究所的教授安妮·马斯顿（Dr. Anne Maston）博士。
Dr. Maston has spent her career studying competence, risk, and resilience in development, with a focus on positive adaptation in children and families whose lives are threatened by adversity. She directs the Project Competence Research on Risk and Resilience, which includes studying high-risk young people exposed to war, natural disasters, poverty, homeless, and migration. She's also author of the book Ordinary Magic, Resilience in Development, among many other publications. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Maston. Thank you. I'm glad to be here. First, let's start by defining the term resilience. How does psychology explain it? And is everyone resilient or are some people more so than others? Well, there's general agreement that resilience refers to positive adaptation to adversity,
马斯顿博士的职业生涯一直致力于研究发展过程中的能力、风险和韧性，重点关注那些生活受到逆境威胁的儿童和家庭的积极适应。她指导着“能力、风险与韧性研究项目”（Project Competence Research on Risk and Resilience），其中包括研究暴露于战争、自然灾害、贫困、无家可归和移民等高风险环境下的年轻人。她还是《普通魔法：发展中的韧性》（Ordinary Magic, Resilience in Development）一书的作者，并发表了许多其他著作。欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，马斯顿博士。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。首先，让我们从定义“韧性”这个词开始。心理学是如何解释它的？每个人都有韧性，还是有些人比其他人更具韧性？嗯，人们普遍认为韧性是指对逆境的积极适应，
but there are different perspectives on how to exactly define resilience. My own view is that we need to think of resilience as the capacity of a system, whether that system is a person, a family, an economy, or a community to adapt successfully to challenges that threaten the functioning, the survival, or the development of that system. And all of us as individuals, we depend on many other systems for our resilience. And I think what we're seeing right now in the midst of this catastrophic pandemic is that we all depend on the resilience of many systems in our lives. We're learning how interdependent we are and how much we depend on the support of other people, our health care system, and many other emergency systems in our communities. So I was going to ask if we're just, are we born with resilience? Is this innate? Do we learn it or is it a little bit of both? Well, we, human beings are prepared to develop resilience in the sense that we have a long history in our species of biological and cultural evolution that has equipped us with tremendous potential for resilience.
但对于如何准确定义韧性，存在不同的观点。我个人的观点是，我们需要将韧性视为一个系统的能力，无论这个系统是一个人、一个家庭、一个经济体还是一个社区，它能够成功地适应那些威胁到该系统功能、生存或发展的挑战。我们每个人作为个体，我们的韧性都依赖于许多其他系统。我认为我们现在在这一灾难性疫情中所看到的是，我们都依赖于生活中许多系统的韧性。我们正在学习我们是多么相互依存，以及我们多么依赖于其他人、我们的医疗保健系统以及我们社区中许多其他应急系统的支持。所以我本来想问，我们是天生就具备韧性吗？这是与生俱来的吗？是我们学来的，还是两者兼而有之？嗯，我们人类已经准备好发展韧性，因为我们的物种有着悠久的生物和文化进化史，这赋予了我们巨大的韧性潜力。
But we all have to develop and have that potential nurtured. So it's a combination of the capacity that human beings have as part of their heritage, but also what they learn through experience and education and good nurturing. So if I'm a parent, how do I build resilience in my children? What are some of the things that I should do and not do to help them become resilient when they grow up? Well, nurturing resilience in children is a lot like building children who are healthy and competent. because many of the most important protective factors for resilience also contribute to generally good development. They help us get through life in basic ways as we grow older. But in terms of building resilience, I think the ways that parents have to work is to balance what they do.
但我们都需要发展并培养这种潜力。所以这是人类作为其遗产一部分所具备的能力，以及通过经验、教育和良好的养育所学到的东西的结合。那么，如果我是一位家长，我该如何培养孩子的韧性呢？为了让他们长大后变得坚韧，我应该做些什么，不应该做些什么？嗯，培养孩子的韧性就像培养健康和有能力的孩子一样。因为韧性的许多最重要的保护因素也有助于整体上的良好发展。随着我们年龄的增长，它们以基本的方式帮助我们度过一生。但在建立韧性方面，我认为家长们需要努力的是平衡他们所做的事情。
Parents are always trying to strike a balance between providing protection and the fact. freedom to learn and grow so that kids get ready for life. And so, you know, on the one hand, parents want to support their children, particularly in dangerous situations. We, our urge is to protect, but children also need experience with adapting and learning how to get up after they fall down. And I think it's helpful to think of this in terms of our immune system. You know, we all have an immune system and it also develops. And we've learned from science over the years that in order to develop a healthy immune system, you really need to have some exposure to challenges. And we even give our children inoculations to challenge them further, to boost up their immune
家长们总是试图在提供保护和给予学习与成长的自由之间取得平衡，以便孩子们为生活做好准备。所以，你知道，一方面，家长们想要支持他们的孩子，特别是在危险的情况下。我们，我们的冲动是保护，但孩子们也需要适应和学习在跌倒后如何站起来的经验。我认为从我们的免疫系统的角度来思考这个问题是有帮助的。你知道，我们都有一个免疫系统，它也在发展。多年来我们从科学中了解到，为了发展一个健康的免疫系统，你确实需要接触一些挑战。我们甚至给孩子们接种疫苗来进一步挑战他们，以增强他们的免疫
system. And I think the same thing is true for building resilience. Children need some experience. with adversity so you can overdo protection. In the case of very dangerous situations, of course, we step in as parents. But we're all striking a balance and it's important for parents to appreciate that they know their children best. They know what their children are capable of. They can pay attention. When do my children need support and when do they need to build the confidence of doing something on their own? That's caused to mind for me the concept of helicopter parenting, which is fairly common in the U.S. right now, at least among more privileged families. Is this something that is hurting our kids' resilience? I would imagine that in some situations, it may be limiting the confidence that our children develop about what they can do. But the notion of helicopter parenting probably has a lot to do with, you know, the expectations and resources. our children have. I certainly think that there are parents and situations where there's a little
系统。我认为建立韧性也是同样的道理。孩子们需要一些面对逆境的经验，所以保护过度是有可能的。当然，在非常危险的情况下，我们作为家长会介入。但我们都在寻求平衡，重要的是家长要意识到他们最了解自己的孩子。他们知道自己的孩子有什么能力。他们可以多加留意。我的孩子什么时候需要支持，什么时候需要建立自己做事的信心？这让我想到了目前在美国，至少在较优越的家庭中相当普遍的“直升机式育儿”概念。这是否正在损害我们孩子的韧性？我想在某些情况下，这可能会限制孩子们对自己能做什么的信心。但“直升机式育儿”的概念可能与我们孩子所拥有的期望和资源有很大关系。我当然认为，在某些家长和情况下，确实存在一点
bit too much support in the sense that children need to build up a sense that they can do things on their own. They need to have challenges, not too extreme. Just like when you get an inoculation, you don't want something that's going to make you ill. We provide a challenge that children can respond to. But all kids need a chance to, you know, figure things out on their own. And I think our job as parents is to provide the kind of opportunities to gradually develop confidence and skills and what you can do on your own. And, you know, maybe we live in a time of anxiety. And I think when parents get anxious, they may step in and hover a little bit too much. So with what What is happening to us today having to maintain social distance and basically shelter in place,
过多的支持，因为孩子们需要建立一种他们可以独立完成事情的感觉。他们需要面对挑战，而不是太极端的挑战。就像接种疫苗一样，你不需要那种会让你生病的东西。我们提供孩子们能够应对的挑战。但所有的孩子都需要一个机会，你知道，自己去弄清楚事情。我认为我们作为家长的职责是提供机会，让他们逐渐发展信心和技能，以及独立完成事情的能力。而且，你知道，也许我们生活在一个充满焦虑的时代。我认为当家长感到焦虑时，他们可能会介入并过度干预。那么，随着今天发生在我们身上的事情，不得不保持社交距离并基本上居家避疫，
this is very different from the kinds of trauma that we think of as really testing our resilience, like wars, floods, earthquakes, disasters. But on the other hand, it's something that's pretty unique in modern existence. Do you think that this pandemic and what we're going through right now will test our resilience in the same way as those other types of events? Or is this something completely different? Well, I think it's similar in many ways. be an extremely challenging. But the word I keep hearing people use right now is surreal. And I think that word captures the feeling that a life is being so utterly altered by something that we cannot even see that can kill us and harm our loved ones. In the case of something like a tornado or a building
这与我们认为真正考验我们韧性的创伤类型（如战争、洪水、地震、灾难）非常不同。但另一方面，这是现代生活中非常独特的事情。你认为这次疫情以及我们现在所经历的一切会像那些其他类型的事件一样考验我们的韧性吗？还是这完全是另一回事？嗯，我认为它在许多方面是相似的，都是极具挑战性的。但我现在一直听到人们用的词是“超现实”。我认为这个词捕捉到了那种感觉，即生活被某种我们甚至看不见、却能杀死我们并伤害我们所爱之人的东西彻底改变了。在龙卷风或建筑物
being destroyed. We see the damage. And I think the images that make us realize how threatening this situation is are the ones we see on television of, you know, emergency rooms and the hospitals that are overwhelmed. I think those convey the same sense of urgency as we see during a war zone. or during the aftermath of a natural disaster. But I think it's different in the sense that we look outside our windows, most of us, and the world looks perfectly normal.
被摧毁的情况下，我们能看到破坏。我认为让我们意识到这种情况有多么危险的画面，就是我们在电视上看到的那些不堪重负的急诊室和医院。我认为这些画面传达了与我们在战区或自然灾害发生后所看到的同样的紧迫感。但我认为它在某种意义上是不同的，因为我们大多数人看向窗外时，世界看起来完全正常。
Except everybody's out taking a walk. We're trying to digest that, you know, social contact is dangerous in many ways. And we can't see the danger. So should we be limited? the amount of media that our kids see right now because they will see those images and just sort of stick to the stress of everybody wears a mask now? Well, I think that, of course, the answer to that question depends a lot on the age of the children. But I think not only should we limit the media exposure to the situation of our children, but also to ourselves.
除了每个人都在外面散步。我们正在努力消化这样一个事实：社交接触在许多方面是危险的。而且我们看不见这种危险。那么我们是否应该限制孩子们现在看到的媒体数量？因为他们会看到那些画面，并可能陷入每个人现在都戴口罩的压力中？嗯，我认为这个问题的答案在很大程度上取决于孩子的年龄。但我认为，我们不仅应该限制孩子们接触有关这种情况的媒体，也应该限制我们自己。
I mean, I certainly have found that as time goes on, I'm beginning to monitor and watch out for how much time I spend watching the news because there's a lot of repeating and there's a lot of dire situations portrayed on the news. And I've realized that I can only handle so much of that. And it begins to affect what I'm thinking about, how well I'm sleeping. So I think that parents also have to monitor their own media exposure to the news about the pandemic, at the same time wanting to stay informed. I also think that, you know, very young children, you have to be very careful and be aware that children may be watching when you're looking at the news. We've learned there's been quite a bit of research showing that media exposure can, you know, affect children. make them feel anxious or trauma symptoms. And sometimes we're not paying attention to what our kids are hearing.
我的意思是，我当然发现随着时间的推移，我开始监控和注意我花多少时间看新闻，因为新闻中有很多重复的内容，而且描绘了很多可怕的情况。我意识到我只能承受那么多。它开始影响我的思考和睡眠质量。所以我认为家长们在想要保持知情的同时，也必须监控自己对疫情新闻的媒体接触。我还认为，对于非常年幼的孩子，你必须非常小心，并意识到当你查看新闻时，孩子们可能正在观看。我们已经了解到，有相当多的研究表明媒体接触可以，你知道，影响孩子，使他们感到焦虑或产生创伤症状。有时我们并没有注意孩子们在听什么。
That raises a question in my mind around whether there is a limit to the resilience in people. And I presume it would be different for everyone. But is there sort of a bank of resilience that we all draw upon? Well, I think that many aspects of resilience are limited, but they're renewable. And, you know, our resilience is always changing. And for example, if you don't feel well, you won't have as much resilience as when you do. If you don't get enough sleep, you won't have as much resilience and so forth.
这在我脑海中引发了一个问题，即人们的韧性是否有极限。我想这对每个人来说都是不同的。但我们是否都有一个可以汲取的“韧性银行”？嗯，我认为韧性的许多方面是有限的，但它们是可以更新的。而且，你知道，我们的韧性总是在变化。例如，如果你感觉不舒服，你的韧性就不会像你感觉良好时那样强。如果你睡眠不足，你的韧性就不会那么强，以此类推。
But, you know, just like our immune system, under difficult circumstances, we do have the capacity as parents and people to surge. We do have surge capacity, but that may be temporary. We can get depleted. If we, you know, day after day after day, if you are working hard to deal with challenging things, you can simply get exhausted and overwhelmed. And then we need to kind of step back and try to replenish and restore our capacity. I have a colleague and friend who's a retired surgeon who talks about this in terms of a resilience bank account that we all store up resilience, but under dire circumstances, we use up that capacity and it can get depleted. And he likes to recommend practices ranging from mindfulness or gratitude practice to other habits of health. and well-being, like getting enough sleep and eating well and staying in touch with people
但是，你知道，就像我们的免疫系统一样，在困难的情况下，我们作为家长和个人确实有能力激增。我们确实有“激增能力”，但这可能是暂时的。我们可能会被耗尽。如果你，你知道，日复一日地努力应对具有挑战性的事情，你可能会简单地感到精疲力竭和不知所措。然后我们需要退后一步，尝试补充和恢复我们的能力。我有一位退休外科医生的同事兼朋友，他谈到这一点时用的是“韧性银行账户”，即我们都储存韧性，但在严峻的情况下，我们用尽了这种能力，它可能会被耗尽。他喜欢推荐从正念或感恩练习到其他健康和幸福习惯的各种做法，比如保证充足的睡眠、饮食健康以及与你关心的人保持联系，
that you care about, all in an effort to try to keep your stores, your bank account of resilience full as needed. But, you know, in a crisis like we're seeing, particularly for health care workers and other first responders and their families, it's extremely difficult day after day, you can get worn down by the strain and stress of this chronic adversity. It can wear you out. And that we have to watch out for how exhausted we are because it's very difficult to, as a parent, particularly, to meet the responsibilities we may have to children, grandchildren and others if we are completely depleted.
所有这些都是为了努力保持你的储备，即你的韧性银行账户在需要时是充足的。但是，你知道，在像我们现在看到的这种危机中，特别是对于医护人员和其他急救人员及其家人来说，日复一日地面对这种慢性逆境的压力和紧张，确实非常困难，这会让你精疲力竭。我们必须注意我们有多么疲惫，因为作为家长，如果我们完全耗尽了，就很难履行我们对孩子、孙辈和其他人可能承担的责任。
What might be the aftermath of all of this? I mean, especially as you're talking about, the first responders and people who are really suffering extreme stressors, are we going to see people needing treatment for PTSD in the wake of this whenever it ends? It's certainly possible for some of the folks who are having really difficult experiences to develop post-traumatic stress symptoms. I think that our observations over many years in research are that, you know, you will see that in some individuals, particularly individuals who've had to deal with a huge load of adversity without a whole lot of support. On the other hand, if you have individuals who do have a lot of support or you have a good recovery, you know, in the aftermath, if there's, you know, a lot of support and recovery for people. Generally speaking, people recover very well from adversity. But I think the greatest dangers are for people who enter this situation already stressed for whatever reason or people who are, have extremely high exposure to traumatic experiences.
这一切的后果可能是什么？我的意思是，特别是正如你所说的，急救人员和那些真正遭受极端压力的人，当这一切结束时，我们会看到人们需要治疗创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）吗？对于一些经历非常困难的人来说，出现创伤后应激症状当然是有可能的。我认为我们多年来的研究观察是，你知道，你会看到这种情况发生在一些个体身上，特别是那些不得不应对巨大逆境而没有太多支持的个体。另一方面，如果你有得到很多支持的个体，或者在事后有很好的恢复，你知道，如果人们有很多支持和恢复。总的来说，人们从逆境中恢复得非常好。但我认为最大的危险在于那些因为某种原因已经处于压力之下的人，或者那些极度暴露于创伤经历中的人。
And I think we're getting, all of us are getting a sense of that from the reports in the media or from people we know who are first responders, that certainly there is a lot of traumatic experiences happening. We also have many people experiencing loss and grief and a unique kind of grief that comes with being unable to have the traditional ceremonies and rituals of practice, whether it's cultural or religious practices by which we say our farewells and celebrate the lives of people we lose. And those may be delayed and happen again in the future, but it's really hard to say goodbye without interpersonal contact.
我认为我们所有人通过媒体报道或通过我们认识的急救人员，都对这一点有所了解，确实有很多创伤性经历正在发生。我们也有许多人正在经历失去和悲伤，这是一种独特的悲伤，来自于无法举行传统的仪式和习俗，无论是文化还是宗教习俗，我们通过这些方式来告别并庆祝我们失去的人的生命。这些仪式可能会被推迟并在未来再次举行，但在没有面对面接触的情况下告别真的很难。
And you see the first responders trying to help out, nurses trying to help people say goodbye to their loved ones via the media, you know, via phones and other things. But I think that loss is really difficult when you're separated from people. And I think we will have to have some focus on how do you recover, how do you celebrate lives of people we've lost later on. But I do think that people come together in this kind of situation and they, you know, connect in new ways. and discover new strengths that they have. I think that we mobilize in the context of this kind of emergency and adversity.
你看到急救人员试图提供帮助，护士试图通过媒体，你知道，通过电话和其他方式帮助人们与亲人告别。但我认为当你与人分离时，那种失去感真的很难受。我认为我们必须关注以后如何恢复，如何庆祝我们失去的人的生命。但我确实认为人们在这种情况下会团结起来，他们，你知道，以新的方式建立联系，并发现他们拥有的新力量。我认为我们在这种紧急情况和逆境中动员起来。
We don't just experience stress. We discover that we have reserves. We discover the strengths we have. We connect with people. And so I think you often see, along with a surge of danger, You often see human capabilities mobilized at many different levels. And we're still responding now, but you can see it all around at government levels and local levels, people beginning to respond by trying to mobilize and coordinate what they do.
我们不仅仅是经历压力。我们发现我们有储备。我们发现我们拥有的力量。我们与人建立联系。所以我认为你经常会看到，伴随着危险的激增，你经常会看到人类的能力在许多不同层面上被动员起来。我们现在仍在应对，但你可以随处看到，在政府层面和地方层面，人们开始通过尝试动员和协调他们的行动来做出反应。
Yeah, certainly I know that's happening in a lot of neighborhoods where I live. People are shopping for each other or making masks or just doing things because they feel so powerless, I think. Right. One of the areas that you've researched is adaptive emotion regulation among parents. Could you explain what that is? And is this something that's going to be really critical right now as we're all kind of sheltering together and stuck for an unknown period of time? Well, there's a lot of research over the years showing that self-regulation in general,
是的，我当然知道在我居住的许多社区里正在发生这种情况。人们互相购物，或者制作口罩，或者只是做些事情，因为我认为他们感到如此无力。对。你研究的领域之一是家长之间的适应性情绪调节。你能解释一下那是什么吗？在我们大家都居家避疫并被困在未知的一段时间里，这是否会变得非常关键？嗯，多年来有大量的研究表明，自我调节通常，
being able to regulate not only your emotions, but also your behavior, your attention, your thoughts and what you do in order to, you know, achieve your goals, that that's very important. And it's important for each of us as individuals and it's important for children, not only to see their parents regulating their emotion, but also to learn from interacting with adults how to regulate their own emotions. And it's a critical aspect of managing stress. and also an important aspect of managing our relationships with other people. And I think what happens when we're stuck at home and, you know, feeling frustrated by how challenging life has become, there's just more emotion to regulate.
能够调节不仅是你的情绪，还有你的行为、注意力、思想以及你所做的事情，以便，你知道，实现你的目标，这是非常重要的。这对我们每个人作为个体来说很重要，对孩子来说也很重要，不仅要看到他们的父母调节他们的情绪，还要通过与成年人的互动学习如何调节他们自己的情绪。这是管理压力和管理我们与他人关系的一个关键方面。我认为当我们被困在家里，并且，你知道，因为生活变得如此具有挑战性而感到沮丧时，会有更多的情绪需要调节。
There's, you know, and children have bigger emotions as well. And so there's a lot more demand placed on our capacity to regulate how we're feeling, to go. And I think that a lot of the practices people talk about to restore equilibrium or to make deposits in our resilience bank accounts, a lot of those practices have to do with self-regulation. So people try, you know, doing things like mindfulness practice or yoga or getting some exercise or listening to music or, you know, doing all kinds of things to try to calm our minds and settle our anxieties. There are many different ways to do this. And there are also religious practices ranging from prayer to meditation to try to do the same thing. And as the demands grow on us during this crisis, I think it's important to pay more attention to the ways that we regulate how we're feeling.
有，你知道，孩子们也有更大的情绪。因此，对我们调节自己感受的能力提出了更多的要求。我认为人们谈论的许多恢复平衡或向我们的韧性银行账户存款的做法，很多都与自我调节有关。所以人们尝试，你知道，做一些事情，比如正念练习、瑜伽、锻炼、听音乐，或者，你知道，做各种各样的事情来尝试平静我们的思想并平息我们的焦虑。有很多不同的方法可以做到这一点。还有各种宗教习俗，从祈祷到冥想，试图做同样的事情。随着这场危机中对我们的要求增加，我认为关注我们调节自己感受的方式变得更加重要。
that we first of all pay attention to how we're doing. And sometimes you don't realize that you're getting anxious and tense and that you begin to feel it in your body. And then I think it's important part of self-care to try to do things that are relaxing. Some of those may be yoga or exercise of other kinds, but others may be listening to music, distracting ourselves or activities like cooking and cleaning or doing things together with a family or calling a friend.
我们首先要关注我们做得如何。有时你并没有意识到你正在变得焦虑和紧张，并且你开始在身体上感觉到它。然后我认为自我护理的一个重要部分是尝试做一些放松的事情。其中一些可能是瑜伽或其他形式的锻炼，但另一些可能是听音乐、分散注意力，或者像烹饪、打扫卫生、与家人一起做事情或给朋友打电话这样的活动。
And I think that many people around the world are doing lots of things to try to draw on their resilience and including thinking of different ways to kind of calm down their fears. And, you know, some of them may be actions to try to reduce exposure, like I was talking about with the media, trying to be careful, how much exposure you have to terrible news on television. But there are other things that people find very helpful when they're trying to control their emotions. And some of them are activities. They may be helping other people, fixing things around the house. getting organized. There's many different and creative ways that people manage the emotions they have, whether those emotions are fears or anxieties. And let's face it, right now, a lot of our fears
我认为世界各地的许多人都在做很多事情来尝试利用他们的韧性，包括想出不同的方法来平息他们的恐惧。而且，你知道，其中一些可能是为了减少接触的行动，就像我刚才谈到的媒体一样，尝试小心你接触电视上可怕新闻的程度。但还有其他一些人们在试图控制情绪时发现非常有帮助的事情。其中一些是活动。它们可能是帮助他人、修理房子周围的东西、整理东西。人们管理他们所拥有的情绪的方式有很多种且富有创造力，无论这些情绪是恐惧还是焦虑。让我们面对现实吧，现在，我们的许多恐惧
and anxieties are realistic. But we can't think about them all the time. We have to give ourselves breaks. And I think there's many strategies being talked about in the news and on television, too, about what we can do. There's special programs that I think are inspirational and that can have the effect of helping us settle our anxieties. I know you've been studying resilience forever, and I'm very curious about the idea, the concept that in some families, they may be very dysfunctional,
和焦虑是现实的。但我们不能一直想着它们。我们必须给自己休息的时间。我认为新闻和电视上也在讨论许多策略，关于我们可以做什么。我认为有一些特别的节目是鼓舞人心的，可以起到帮助我们平息焦虑的作用。我知道你一直在研究韧性，我非常好奇这样一个概念，即在一些家庭中，他们可能非常功能失调，
and maybe there are a bunch of kids. and one of them turns out to be a huge success and the others are disasters. And I'm wondering how resilience fits into all of that. And what are the characteristics of that one person who is able to pull out of a very dysfunctional family life and move beyond it and the others never can? I think the first thing to remember is that every individual has different capabilities. and different experiences. Even people in the same family, even identical twins, don't have the same experiences. So people have different vulnerabilities. They have different life experiences. And some children, you know, may just through happenstance meet important mentors or helpers
也许有一群孩子，其中一个变得非常成功，而其他人则是灾难。我想知道韧性是如何融入这一切的。那个能够从非常功能失调的家庭生活中走出来并超越它的人，与那些永远无法做到的人，他们有什么特征？我认为首先要记住的是，每个人都有不同的能力和不同的经历。即使是同一个家庭的人，甚至是同卵双胞胎，也没有相同的经历。所以人们有不同的脆弱性。他们有不同的生活经历。有些孩子，你知道，可能只是偶然遇到了重要的导师或帮手
out there. They may develop different friendships. But people have many different kinds of of internal and external supports can shape the resilience that we have. And sometimes it can be something as simple as, you know, one child and a family meeting up with a mentor, coach who plays an important role as a protective factor. In other cases, it may be that one child compared to another has less or more vulnerability due to maybe some early experiences they had or some illness they had. But there are just so many different influences on the capacities that we develop to handle adversity.
在那里。他们可能会发展出不同的友谊。但人们拥有许多不同种类的内部和外部支持，可以塑造我们拥有的韧性。有时它可能就像，你知道，一个家庭中的一个孩子遇到了一个导师、教练，他作为保护因素发挥了重要作用。在其他情况下，可能是因为一些早期的经历或疾病，一个孩子相比另一个孩子有更少或更多的脆弱性。但影响我们发展的应对逆境的能力的因素实在太多了。
And they're just individual differences that arise, partly through our genetic heritage and partly through the experiences that we have as our genes interact with everything else going on as we develop. And people vary in their sensitivity. So some children are more sensitive to the adversity they experience. And those very same children may also be sensitive if they get fortunate enough to come across a teacher or a mentor out there who recognizes the. potential of that person and, you know, works with them and encourages them. They're sensitive
而且存在着个体差异，部分源于我们的遗传遗产，部分源于我们在发展过程中基因与周围一切事物相互作用所产生的经历。人们的敏感度各不相同。所以有些孩子对他们经历的逆境更敏感。而正是这些孩子，如果他们足够幸运，遇到了一位认可他们潜力的老师或导师，并与他们一起工作并鼓励他们，他们也会变得敏感。他们对环境中的积极经历和消极经历同样敏感。
to positive experiences in the environment as well as negative ones. But, you know, there's so many individual differences and so many differences in the life experiences that people have that it's not surprising really that in the same family you can have different outcomes. I think what mainly surprises us about that is that a deep recognition that we all have that family matters. So, you know, if you have a family that functions really well, generally speaking, the kids will do fine unless, you know, they have some serious kind of vulnerability or negative experiences. But when you have a family that is growing up with adversity and, you know, what surprises you is not that, you know, the children are struggling, but rather that you have a child who is managing to make it out of there. And it's a recognition that families play a big role in the experiences that children have. And yet sometimes it's just the luck of finding that mentor, teacher.
但是，你知道，存在着如此多的个体差异和如此多的生活经历差异，所以同一个家庭中会出现不同的结果也就不足为奇了。我认为对此感到惊讶的主要原因是，我们都深刻认识到家庭很重要。所以，你知道，如果你的家庭功能非常好，总的来说，孩子们会做得很好，除非，你知道，他们有一些严重的脆弱性或负面经历。但当你有一个在逆境中成长的家庭时，你知道，让你惊讶的不是孩子们在挣扎，而是你有一个孩子设法从那里走了出来。这是一种认识，即家庭在孩子们的经历中扮演着重要角色。然而有时，这仅仅是找到那个导师、老师的运气。
That's right. I've known, you know, over the years and the research I've done, there have been many different stories of what made a difference where, you know, a turning point. And sometimes the turning point was a person, like a neighbor. Sometimes it was a teacher who took a special interest in a child. Sometimes it was children getting older and realizing, you know, their own brain development began to tell them, you know, this isn't such a good idea. to be in trouble all the time. And they began to look around for new opportunities. It's clear to me that opportunity plays an important role in resilience.
没错。多年来，在我所做的研究中，我知道有很多关于什么产生了差异的故事，你知道，转折点。有时转折点是一个人，比如邻居。有时是一位对孩子特别感兴趣的老师。有时是孩子们长大了，意识到，你知道，他们自己的大脑发育开始告诉他们，你知道，一直惹麻烦并不是一个好主意。他们开始寻找新的机会。对我来说很清楚，机会在韧性中起着重要作用。
And that's why, you know, it's really important that we recognize right now the disparities that we're seeing with this pandemic. They're the children who are already living in unstable families or living in poverty, are facing more adversity than kids who have been living with more advantages. And children who have in homes with more space in them or more resources of like high-speed internet and better computers and so forth, they have some advantages and opportunities to make it through the current homeschooling, for example, than children who have no internet connection and no resources at home or people who can help them with their homework and so forth.
这就是为什么，你知道，我们现在必须认识到我们在这场疫情中看到的差异非常重要。那些已经生活在不稳定家庭或生活在贫困中的孩子，比那些生活在更有优势环境中的孩子面临更多的逆境。而那些拥有更多空间、更多资源（如高速互联网和更好的电脑等）的家庭中的孩子，与那些没有互联网连接、家里没有资源或没有人能帮助他们做作业的孩子相比，在应对当前的居家学习方面确实有一些优势和机会。
There's a term in psychology that talks about what happens after things like this, post-traumatic growth. Do you see opportunities for that? Is that something that you look into as well? Well, generally, post-traumatic growth refers to this phenomenon where some people, actually appear to improve in functioning. There's something about engaging in responding to adversity that seems to mobilize some individuals and they come away feeling stronger or with a deeper awareness of the value of life or just able to function better and handle things better. I think that's been studied more extensively in adults and parents than it has in children.
心理学中有一个术语谈论像这样的事情之后会发生什么，即“创伤后成长”。你看到了这方面的机会吗？这也是你研究的内容吗？嗯，通常，创伤后成长指的是这样一种现象，即有些人实际上表现出功能上的改善。在应对逆境的过程中，似乎有一些东西动员了一些个体，他们感到更强大，或者对生命的价值有了更深刻的认识，或者只是能够更好地发挥功能并更好地处理事情。我认为这在成人和家长身上比在儿童身上得到了更广泛的研究。
Very young children, you know, certainly they gain some resilience from, you know, learning how to manage stressors on a scale that are appropriate for children. But most of the research on post-traumatic stress has been done with adults. And I think that's because adults have just have more capabilities and resources to mobilize in the face of a challenge. But certainly that's been reported both anecdotally in the literature, and there's some research, still limited on that phenomenon. I think there's a broader phenomenon that's widely reported, which is this notion of stress inoculation or stealing effect. just the general idea that we do, if it's not too much stress, that we do learn and gain from some exposure to challenges that kind of teach us about our own resources and what to do and how to handle things. And, you know, one form of this, we see all the time in schools that our children go to.
非常年幼的孩子，你知道，他们当然从学习如何以适合儿童的规模管理压力源中获得了一些韧性。但大多数关于创伤后压力的研究都是针对成年人进行的。我认为这是因为成年人有更多的能力和资源来应对挑战。但这种情况在文献中确实有轶事报道，并且关于这种现象的研究仍然有限。我认为有一个更广泛的现象被广泛报道，即“压力接种”或“磨练效应”的概念。这只是一个普遍的想法，即如果我们确实，如果压力不是太大，我们确实会从一些面对挑战的经历中学习并获得收益，这些经历教会了我们关于我们自己的资源以及如何做和如何处理事情。而且，你知道，我们一直在学校里看到这种形式，
things like fire drills and lockdown drills are a form of stress inoculation. We're not only teaching children what to do. We're preparing teachers and children for how to function when there's something alarming happening. But it's a small dose. We don't set real fires to help children learn how to deal with fire. We practice and expose them to the children. challenge of, you know, hearing the alarm go off and figuring out what to do. And some of these exposures are really stressful for kids. And that varies with the individual child. One of my
比如消防演习和封锁演习就是一种压力接种。我们不仅在教孩子们做什么。我们还在为老师和孩子们准备当发生令人担忧的事情时如何发挥功能。但这只是小剂量。我们不会为了帮助孩子们学习如何处理火灾而设置真正的火灾。我们练习并让他们接触到挑战，你知道，听到警报响起并弄清楚该做什么。其中一些接触对孩子们来说确实压力很大。这因个体孩子而异。我的一个
children was really scared of the fire alarm. And it took me a while to realize that she was conveniently absent from school whenever there was a fire drill. So, you know, neither she nor her teacher nor her parents, it didn't dawn on us that there was a regularity in her absences. But she had figured out. Yeah, and she's sensitive to loud noises. And she didn't, the sound of the fire alarm scared her more than everything else that went along with it. Well, Dr. Maston, this has been extremely helpful information.
孩子真的很害怕火警。我花了一段时间才意识到，每当有消防演习时，她都会“方便地”缺席学校。所以，你知道，无论是她、她的老师还是她的父母，我们都没有意识到她的缺席是有规律的。但她已经弄清楚了。是的，她对巨大的噪音很敏感。而且她不喜欢，火警的声音比随之而来的所有其他事情都更让她害怕。好吧，马斯顿博士，这些信息非常有帮助。
I hope that people who are listening to this podcast feel more reasonable. resilient as a result of some of the situations that you have described and some of the techniques. So I really appreciate your joining us. Well, thank you. It's been a pleasure. And I just want to close by saying that there really is, you know, human beings have a lot of capacity for resilience, but it's not unlimited. And it's important that we look out for each other and help together. I mean, we have the capability of generating a lot of capacity.
我希望听这个播客的人在听了你描述的一些情况和一些技巧后，会感到更具韧性。所以我真的很感谢你的加入。嗯，谢谢。这是我的荣幸。我只想最后说一句，确实，你知道，人类有很多韧性能力，但它不是无限的。重要的是我们要互相照顾，共同帮助。我的意思是，我们有能力产生很多能力。
to overcome adversity when we coordinate what we do and work together across many different levels, not just individuals, but also as families and communities and states and governments. Well, that's very helpful. And again, thank you. And I'd like to say thank you to our listeners. If you have any comments or ideas that you want to share about our podcast, send an email to Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology. all one word at APA.org. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website and download past episodes at www.
当我们协调我们的行动并在许多不同层面上共同努力时，不仅是作为个人，而且是作为家庭、社区、州和政府，我们有能力克服逆境。嗯，这非常有帮助。再次感谢你。我也想对我们的听众说声谢谢。如果你有任何想分享的关于我们播客的评论或想法，请发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，at APA.org。你可以在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。你也可以访问我们的网站并下载过去的剧集，网址是 www.
www. speakingof psychology.org. Thanks again for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
www. speakingof psychology.org。再次感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。